nuevamente economía en nuestro espacio
de france 24 directo américa daniel
hablando no vamos a empezar con una
noticia bien grave no ya 40 millones de
personas más padecieron de hambre en
todo el mundo en el año 2021 claro que
si raúl miremos las cifras la
organización de naciones unidas para la
agricultura y la alimentación es la fao
y la unión europea presentaron un
informe en el que señalan que 193
millones de personas en todo el mundo no
tienen el suficiente para comer cada día
esos 40 millones más que un año atrás la
situación ha empeorado en 53 países y el
informe culpa al cambio climático a las
guerras y a la pandemia de kobe de 19
pases en hambre aguda cuyo fenómeno lo
explican a continuación
las familias vulnerables no pueden
acceder a suficientes alimentos para
comer todos los días como resultado
tienen que emplear mecanismos de
supervivencia de emergencia como vender
activos saltarse las comidas
involucrarse a veces en comportamientos
muy peligrosos
y por supuesto esta situación también se
refleja en la desnutrición aguda
particularmente en niños muy pequeños de
menos de cinco años en última instancia
desde luego pérdida de vidas y la unión
europea se alista para evitar el
petróleo ruso annie pero le faltan votos
la guerra bolio nos hace usted está de
acuerdo conmigo pero conmigo pero yo
creo que esta es la medida más osada de
este estudio paquete de sanciones que
analiza el bloque comunitario y tiene
que ser aprobada por unanimidad por los
27 miembros pero hungría y eslovaquia no
están de acuerdo porque dependen del
petróleo ruso en un 96 por ciento y en
un 58 por ciento respectivamente la
convención europea que está haciendo
pues está dispuesta a seguirles
permitiendo la compra de crudo ruso
hasta 2023 en un intento de que apoyen
la propuesta
en el oro lijas nos aseguraremos que
esto se haga de manera ordenada para
asegurar rutas de suministro
alternativas y al mismo tiempo minimizar
el impacto en los mercados globales por
eso es que en un período de seis meses
prescindiremos del petróleo crudo ruso y
para final de año de los productos
refinados
por supuesto no será fácil algunos de
estados miembros son fuertemente
dependientes del petróleo ruso pero
tenemos que hacerlo militando en el vaso
o el pacto y simply have you to witch y
russian y evitó caer en default claro
este miércoles terminaba un plazo de 30
días para que el país pagará cerca de
650 millones de dólares de los bonos que
expiraron el mes pasado ellos tienen un
periodo de 30 días de gracia el
ministerio de finanzas dijo haber hecho
el pago el viernes a una cuenta del
citigroup en dólares y de esta manera de
renunció a su amenaza de que pagaría en
rublos porque no tenía cómo acceder a
sus divisas internacionales el país
tiene una deuda en bonos extranjeros que
se calculan unos 40 mil millones de
dólares y el kremlin estima que tiene
alrededor de 640 mil millones en divisas
y en reservas de oro pero occidente
tiene gran parte de ellas congeladas y
que oligarca se despidió de rusia
precisamente él se llama oleg 5 quien
dice que la semana pasada se publicó a
vender por un precio irrisorio su banco
digital tinkoff que es el segundo
privado más grande de rusia tiene más de
20 millones de clientes y todo dice el
por cuenta de haber criticado el kremlin
pues habla de la deshumanización del
régimen ruso en una publicación en
instagram que veremos a continuación él
señaló que ni un billón o millón vale
las lágrimas de un niño y agrega que lo
perdió todo pero que no ha perdido su
alma no puedo ganar dinero fácilmente en
un país que está en guerra con un vecino
matando civiles y niños fue la
conclusión y es que él vendió la semana
pasada el 35 por ciento que tenía en el
capital de este banco y también vendió
su participación en la dacha esta es una
empresa de alojamiento de lujo así es
indicadores económicos todo el mercado
bursátil raúl hoy está pendiente como ya
lo habíamos dicho en la sesión del
martes de la reserva federal las bolsas
asiáticas cerraron a la baja con algunas
como en tokio todavía cerradas por ser
día festivo la misma situación en europa
donde las caídas sin embargo no son o
son mejor mínimas en medio de la cautela
por las decisiones que tome el banco
central de eeuu lo que sí está subiendo
con fuerza es el precio del petróleo
avanza más del 4 por ciento por este
plan europeo de vetar el crudo ruso dale
gracias por toda la información
económica nos vamos directo hasta parís